welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is paulina Oh Joey sp ho an assistant
professor of political science at Yale
University professor otua specializes in
contemporary political theory and the
history of political thought today we
talk with her about her book the time of
popular sovereignty process and the
Democratic state in it she offers a new
theory of democratic peoplehood laying
the foundations for a new theory of
democratic legitimacy welcome Professor
Oak Choa I am glad to be here
let's talk about your book what is the
question you are trying to address in it
well nowadays everybody is a Democrat
everybody thinks that democracy is
something desirable and by definition
democracy is the rule of the people
mm-hmm but what is the people and that
is a question that I'm trying to address
this is a very important question in the
theory of democracy but it's a question
that people tend to take for granted or
go around so for example nowadays we
have elections in the United States
there's the electoral process going on
and you hear politicians all the time
saying the American people think the
American people want the American people
think this or that and at the very same
time you see another politician saying
the American people want this other
thing that is exactly the opposite what
the first politician said before and
suddenly you begin to think that this
phrase the American people is completely
empty that it really doesn't mean
anything it's just a strategic device
that politicians use to get ahead of of
the other candidate in an election but
if that were true if if you couldn't
make sense of what is the
people or what the people want or
whether the people can decide then how
can you say with a straight face that
you're a Democrat and I think that
there's this problem going on that
people will say with a straight face
that they are Democrat but then they do
not know how to say that it is the
people that actually rules so that's my
main concern
if we are committed Democrats what would
the people have to be in order for
democracy to make sense okay and what
led you to pursue this well I'm a
political theorist so you could say that
simply trying to make sense of concepts
within a theory was enough but I also
believe that theories have to be in a
given context and they're only important
to the extent that they are in that
political historical context that we
care about so it is the political
context that I lived through that led me
to this question it's they overlap of my
interesting theory and two political
events that took place in the last
decade that were very very important for
me the first is they're American 2000
election and the second one is the 2006
election in Mexico in the first event I
had just arrived in in the United States
as a PhD student and I remember going to
a bar and watching the election returns
with my friends and I remember we all
said okay let's go to bed because
Florida had been cold and the gore was
being elected so we just went to bed and
I remember waking up the next day and it
hadn't been solved and as you remember
that went on for months months and my
main concern there is how can we say who
is making that decision who is the
people that is eventually going to
decide who's going to be the governor of
this country for or like the president
of this country for them in the next
four years and knowing who gets to
decide was something that really got me
going in trying to figure out who what
is the people and whether I can decide
and this of course
led me to the second event that it's
very interesting but it's also
interesting for personal reasons because
I am a Mexican and I lived through the
process of turning in Mexico from an
authoritarian regime into a democracy
and in this process one could say
culminated in the 2006 election when
something very similar happened in
Mexico you had an election that was too
close to call but unlike the process in
the United States where it ended with a
decision of the Supreme Court in Mexico
there one of the candidates just did not
concede the election him he pointed out
that the procedure had not been the way
it should have been and basically
thought that the legal institutions were
not legitimate and claimed that the
legitimacy of government had to come
back to a popular decision mm-hm and so
he went he brought his movement to the
streets and I was there at some moments
in which people claimed he mobilized up
to two million people on the street and
it was very interesting to see all that
enthusiasm and all that political the
strength of political action but at the
same time I was very skeptical of claims
saying that it is the people who are
making the decision okay and it was that
contrast that got me going and led me to
write the book what did happen in Mexico
well yeah eventually the candidate never
conceded but in the turn of events were
such that in the institution's just got
going and the decision of the newly
elected President Felipe Calderon was
taken as the factor of decision as a
matter of fact he was the president even
though Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador never
considered the election
interesting okay let's talk about your
concept of the people and how it is
different from current thinking well my
concept of the people is that the people
is a prize
so it's not a collection of individuals
it's it's a process that unfolds in time
this is quite different from all current
views so let me just tell you about the
others and why is it different um I
think that when you think about the
people most individuals in the street
the most common view is that the people
is something like a nation is perhaps a
people right so you can say these are
the songs of my people or something of
that kind
um for example in the Bible the most
sisters the Pharaoh let my people go
that is the kind of people that most
people in the street have in mind mm-hmm
but that's not the one that I have in
mind because it's a that's a cultural
construction and a way you could say
that it's also in an ethnic construction
people are have family ties eventually
and I'm concerned about a political view
of the people so another one that a view
of the people that may come to mind is
the people as an economic construction
so for example in the Occupy movement
that has been going on in the last year
there's a lot of talk about the people
but it's the 99% that is those who do
not have political power and do not have
economic power and the people that I
have in mind the people and that
democracy it's everybody because
everybody's supposed to be free and
equal so it precipice is that it's
everybody this happens also when people
I am another idea that comes to mind is
the majority so in America in the
American context especially when people
think about the people's voice or the
people have spoken
they have in mind the majority but if
you just consider the term majority it
presupposes there's a majority of
something of what that whole is the
people that I have in mind in its the
demos that rules
the demos in the democracy and and
trying to figure out that hole is what
got me going that's mostly what comes in
the idea of popular sovereignty and it
contrasts with my idea of the people as
a process that changes in time okay what
do you mean by popular sovereignty I
know that's part of the title of your
book and and you feel it's a problem
well popular sovereignty is the idea
that there is a supreme authority in a
political community so in this case the
people is the supreme authority in the
political community popular sovereignty
like many other terms in political
theory tends to be difficult to define
in its contested depends on what your
idea of the people was her idea of
sovereignty but I think that most people
would agree that sovereignty has to do
with the last instance of appeal so for
example if we go back to the 2000 and C
and 2000 elections in the United States
there was a disagreement and a one group
thought that and the people were saying
one thing and the other thought that and
the decision was to be another and this
decision was contested and there was an
appeal and then another appeal and it
went all the way to the Supreme Court
right and it was eventually the Supreme
Court that made that decision right so
one could say that it was the Supreme
Court that made the decision in the last
instance and it was the Supreme Court
that was sovereign and not the people so
for example if you do if you take it
into Mexico there it was slightly
different in that it went all the way to
the last instance of legal appeal and it
was not decided then so what is the last
instance of appeal well as a matter of
fact it was the people who has to decide
what is going to happen and I wanted to
say that this is something that happens
and in a civil war it's the fact or the
people that decides where it's going to
go or it can be by right that the people
have the right to decide in the last
instance so this is the idea of popular
anteus as it has been in democratic
theory for the last 200 years and it's a
very powerful idea if you think about it
this idea of the people mobilized as the
last instance of Appeal or the last
decider goes hand in hand with the most
moving images of democracy for example
the idea of the French Revolution or the
Revolutionary War in the United States
or the independence Awards that kicked
out colonial powers throughout the world
in the 19th and 20th century and so this
idea of the people together in action
looking for freedom it's very very
powerful but it's also very problematic
and those problems are the ones that I
try to address in my book there and what
are those problems well there one could
say that it's very difficult just to
know when the people have a voice so
it's almost impossible to have consensus
which is this idea of the people as a
collection of individuals coming
together to rule themselves they would
have to agree all of them at the same
time so it's nearly impossible to have
consensus in a big group but that's not
the main concern that I have because
that's very difficult but it's not
impossible
I actually think that it's impossible to
do it if you think that the people is a
collection of individuals why well you
have to first know who is everybody
everybody's not the whole of humankind
it has to be some people so how do you
know who they are well and you could say
that somebody decides but the problem is
that if somebody decides then not
everybody's free and equal in order to
make this important political decision
and have everybody free and equal you'd
have to take a vote but if you take a
vote to decide who's gonna vote that
makes no sense it you'd have you'd need
a people to decide who's the people to
decide who's the people to decide who's
the people that's impossible
so this is not something that I
discovered this is something that people
know is a problem for the last
hundred years but in order to avoid it
and they just say well somebody has to
make the first decision the first card
so it's usually institutions that decide
institutions decide who gets to be a
citizens and and then you get it going
mm-hmm but the problem there is that
what happened in Mexico you know Lopez
Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador said those
institutions are not legitimate
if those institutions are not legitimate
then it should be the people who decides
who gets to be and the problem there is
that the people that utilizes the
institutions and the institutions tell
you who are the people so now you have a
vicious circle not only a regress so you
have the second very difficult problem
in fact impossible problem and the third
one is that even if you decide to bypass
it and you say okay we're just going to
assume that these people was there to
begin with and we're just gonna start
you have the problem of who cave and
original permission to say the founding
fathers to get it going and the second
one is how why even if they have an
agreement at the beginning why are we
bound by the decision that they made
over time so you have these three very
very difficult theoretical problems that
actually play in reality as we could see
in Mexico in 2006 and we could see in
the United States in 2000 the question
of legitimacy springs up again and again
because you don't have this original
beginnings that were a legitimate and so
looking at these problems I think that
the best way to get out of these
problems is to redefine the people so
rather than think that the people is a
group of individuals that get together
and decide what I decided to do is look
at it as an institutional process that
unfolds over time okay and and that
would get to these problems because you
can say that you participate over time
so you can always alter what is going on
and the voice of the people is being
made so you can come in and and the
problem of the original
founding of the state does not come up
and the same happens with legitimizing
because if you keep it open towards the
future this can be solved as you go
along okay let's talk about some of the
practical implications well as I told
you when I got into this problem it was
not the theoretical problem that I was
struck with it was the political
problems that I saw ministry so for
example in the case of floppy sobre door
I am and even in in the case of the the
United States but let me begin with
Mexico I think that the most important
thing is that the institution's are part
of the people you can't simply say a the
people takes takes it from now on and
the institutions are not important
because the people make up the Institute
exactly institutions wouldn't exist
without the people and the other way
around the people wouldn't exist without
the institution's because it's a process
that makes one and the other and over
time so you can't simply let go of the
institution's however and this is the
second implication if the people can
judge institutions so you can have this
stance that allows you to say well are
these institutions legitimate or not and
this is exactly what's going on in
Tahrir Square throughout last year and
all throughout there are countries the
people are in fact saying what is the
legitimacy of these institutions but you
cannot simply ignore them you have it's
they're over the play back and forth
over time that would allow you to say
what is the legitimacy of these
institutions and the third one which I
can see there is the most important is
that if the people is a process
unfolding over time you cannot claim
that the people have said something the
people are always speaking so you can
say that there are certain decisions
that are influenced by the interplay of
ideas that are still going on but you
can all claim the people to yourself
that is a
this theoretical a account allows you to
say why it is wrong to say I represent
the ultimate decision of the people and
a given time so I think that this is
something that we can see every time
that there is a popular mobilization as
it happened last year in the Middle East
and whenever you have claims of a leader
to speak for the people I say very
interesting thank you so much for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your work you're welcome for more
information about professor or Choa and
her work please visit our website at
Yale ddu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible by the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at Yale
you